the Philippines new president isn't
afraid to insult public leaders though
I'm gonna hold on I gotta know mr. Obama
you're gonna what the hell deter she has
made international headlines for his
deadly war on crime and drugs in
particular we will eliminate the drug
lords once and for all his alleged
extrajudicial methods have stoked
outrage and his verbal tirades are
straining ties with the u.s. the
Philippines major military ally for
decades here's the situation the
Philippines is made up of more than
7,000 islands and 100 million people its
economy has grown faster than its major
Southeast Asian neighbors but the
country has high levels of corruption
poverty and crime and it was due Turtles
promised to take on the criminals that
helped him secure a landslide in May's
presidential election I will be a
dictator no doubt about it but only
against the forces of evil criminality
drugs and corruption in government
Duterte honed his methods for tackling
crime as mayor of Davao City known as
The Punisher for his vigilante style
approach Duterte vowed to stamp out
crime within a year of being elected
president some 3-thousand suspected drug
dealers were reported killed in his
first three months in office after the
u.s. the UN and others objected
Duterte threatened to withdraw the
Philippines from the UN maybe we're just
up to decide to separate from the United
Nations and an exploited Layton warning
about us interference push President
Obama to snub a meeting with Duterte so
clearly he's a colorful guy here's the
argument dieter says critics see him as
perhaps the biggest Menace since
Philippine dictator Ferdinand Marcos and
a threat even to democracy
shift away from the us I do not have any
master except the Filipino people nobody
but nobody has been matched by a more
conciliatory approach to China and
Russia China
No
is even discussed the possibility of
direct talks with China over territorial
claims in the South China Sea can call
for restraint and sobriety after the
Philippines won a tribunal ruling
against Chinese claims what remains to
be seen is whether he can maintain the
sky high approval ratings of his first
few months in office and how much
trash-talk a special relationship with
the US can withstand